hello welcome to this video playing my
t.o.o chu ok what about scoring a
convincing win or not in some time
[ __ ] but just win a game that would
be nice and then done that for a while
just back to the 80 to f8 ok blacks
position is solid but usually like it
was like a six bishop a 74 some activity
at last at least ok so i can gain more
space here if I want with d5 yeah maybe
actually I can I can close this position
and just have more space quite a bit
more space and it all happens with tempo
so I'm kind of tempted the yes rien rear
developed all these pieces King edge 898
would be funky but it's probably a
little bit too bad to really be played
yes of some kind of Kings Indian setup
but that's a very very slow King linnean
again this scenario and I don't like so
much to have played before bit okay you
can't have it all and I already have a
lot yet so it's not like I'm complaining
a couple of good options now this is one
of them just trade the bishop if it does
not want to trade a plane 91 33 win this
is at least possible okay it doesn't
mind the trade it seems okay yeah queen
d 4 is a move couple of in a couple of
good ones
you
Michael Knight f6 now really wow I can
just take this okay you can take on d4
that's a pretty awful ending
so 96 is an idea here already and
there's also g4 which is also very
annoying ok I think asking him about a
movie as a good idea because it's not
easy femme to make one Bishop d7 96 is
pretty awful b6 ok
I cannot take this I guess I can take it
maybe it's got to see have some
compensation here 95 or 96 96 actually
keeps yeah it doesn't matter i think
it's both good okay well here i can then
g4 is actually a little bit tricky in
okay I can also just play hooky three
here and cover okay maybe this is a bit
lame my team Reggie for watson also
possibility so i would be one he will
lose the rook still I have worked p 7 at
the end hmm yeah c'mon I have to play
with cook am Knight takes e4 the tactic
here that I only now recognized while
that said that's late okay who didn't
happen it could have been could have
been really tricky and I'd see to hear
oh my
giving him so much here on to this
position amazing it's really amazing
okay so rook takes and things are quite
unclear on do I have some syntactic
available there would be 8b seven I
cannot take with the night at least that
bloodless the night but rook takes might
work i mean i don't quite see why it
shouldn't okay I really don't know why
do I didn't play it but okay
I don't don't see anything great here
geforce blundering f4 which is which is
an issue i can check what kini seven
doesn't do all that much time morning I
don't know come on I'm doing this now
see if I can take on c5 at the end of
this maybe just take with an idea to
irritate me completely night have three
is got some checks coming maybe yeah
yeah 93 I can I can go to jail I can
actually go there my hook is protected
okay so nine to five and four is hanging
though with check maybe just go here I
can also do this not sure if it helps
okay let's take this takes a five check
points look dangerous really do check
check
no one blundering the point wow it was
very very awful check check check check
check check no check black forfeit on
time oh my god and it wasn't very
convincing I mean the style of it was
but not the N Load this this this type
of position I mean this is excellent for
what I get the d4 square and it isn't
any plate c5 I mean this is just not
playable hit all ok so this position I
should just flat-out women I just I
don't don't quite don't quite have the
real feel for it at the moment but we
having g4 is the most known whatever but
I still couldn't play it man this i mean
i was talking about this and the engine
just says it's a william which is very
much possible I just felt and I do it
without any big complications again g
four wins but sorry but this also should
win just grab the porn but it did
cutting amazingly tricky after and keep
pressing the wrong button there after i
went for this passive move again g-force
this is killing black IAM just pushing
the f
it's strange sometimes how you have
those kind of phases and while playing
those games over the course of a couple
of days we simply don't have a good feel
for the position on other times it works
it works fine it's really not easy to
explain yet here this has become tricky
already you know I came into the engine
look like white win season the n92 but
yeah this is also this is good yeah
because now I can I have square cm and
I'm not losing this point I already have
one the b7 pawn yeah and here i mean es
he has player and rook takes and the
engine just gives us move here as I says
i mentioned i really don't know why it
didn't play it couldn't quite figure it
out and here black should be okay again
g4 was winning and hereafter night g3 he
could've won and quite oh this is a big
threat night oops sorry not this one
oops the heck is going on here hey so
this one threatening night f1 if i take
it matter 3 is made and yes this also
going back and taking wow and the engine
actually wants me to sacrifice with this
night and says and this is better for
white so I managed to sacrifice in the
wrong way check is has equal yeah
they're probably tons of mistakes around
10 now from here I think I did a
reasonable job pushing those pawns check
but then yeah it was a matter of I had
11 seconds chapels going all the way
with the night to make sure that I have
a drawing check check
gen chan time whatsoever and managed to
win on time yeah shaky game really shaky
game ok guys thanks for watching